ein Tag essen wie in Thailand viele
meiner Freunde sind nach dem Abi ins
Ausland gefahren und nicht wenige von
ihnen nach Thailand und ich habe sie
immer beneidet wirklich weil ich war die
meiste Zeit meines Lebens einfach hier
in Deutschland und ihr wisst wie gar
nicht esse deshalb würde ich zumindest
gerne das Essen authentisch in den
verschiedenen Ländern der Welt erleben
können deshalb gibt es diese Serie
deshalb werde ich heute einen Tag wie in
Thailand Kochen ich habe so viel gehört
vom thailändischen Essen haben natürlich
auch in Deutschland schon das ein oder
andere probiert und wir probieren heute
gemeinsam authentisch einen Tag
thailändisch zu essen zwei Gerichte
werden wir selbst kochen und eines
werden wir essen gehen ich freue mich
auf alle drei gleichermaßen und ich
würde sagen wir fangen an mit dem
Frühstück willkommen in Thailand
zumindest in einer für den Tag
thailändischen Küche wenn ich alles
richtig mache so auch bei unserem
Frühstück wir haben hier Reis der das
Herzstück von unserem frühstücken und
wir machen heute ein Pony ich hoffe ich
spreche das richtig aus es ist quasi
sowas wie eine Reis Porridge aber
herzhaft wenn in Thailand frühstückt man
eigentlich nicht süß so zum Frühstück
wird direkt Herz was gegessen
reisspeisen surfrei es gibt viele
Variationen aber das für das wir uns
heute entschieden haben ist als ein
geheimer Klassiker angesehen nämlich
reichskonji mit Meatballs und ich sag
mal so ich bin sehr zu haben für etwas
so herzhaftes wir haben natürlich
unseren Reis wir haben gehacktes vom
Schwein wir haben Julienne von Ingwer
also einfach Ingwer Streifen etwas
Zucker Ingwer Frühlingszwiebeln
Hühnerbrühe Sojasauce Sesamöl weißen
Pfeffer das ist alles was wir benötigen
wir fangen an indem wir unseren Reis in
unseren Mixer geben denn man kann Reis
von Vortag benutzen man kann den Reis so
wie wir gerade frisch kochen aber das
wichtigste ist nochmal warm gemacht wird
denn so kann er mehr Flüssigkeit
aufnehmen und dann fügen wir genauso
viel an der Brühe hinzu dass sich das
ganze schön pürieren lässt aber wir
müssen es nicht zu sehr durch weil wir
wollen noch so ein bisschen Struktur wir
wollen keinen feines Püree wir wollen
einen Fondue right dann geben wir jetzt
ein wenig unser Brühe hinzu
wir pürieren das ganze auf geringer
Stufe
wir wollen so wie man es hier sieht auf
jeden Fall noch so den Reis in Teilen
ganz haben ich denke was steht gut
ausgeben das ganze direkt in unseren
Topf hinein ja ja jetzt kocht das ganze
ein dick noch mal aus und es muss jetzt
köcheln wenn das ganze so nach blubbert
können wir jetzt schon mal Sojasoße
dazugeben
ein Esslöffel und ein bisschen und
Fischsoße und nicht irgendeine nicht
irgendeine sondern product auf Thailand
die richtigen tänzt auf jeden Fall dann
kommen noch ein bisschen ich habe extra
eine Mühle umgefüllt weißer Pfeffer rein
jetzt lassen wir das ganze köcheln 10
bis 20 Minuten je länger das so weicher
und samtiger wird das Ganze aber wir
haben in der Zwischenzeit natürlich
trotzdem etwas zu tun denn kommen ja
noch mietballs rein da brauche ich eine
Schüssel in unser Schweine gehacktes
dann das hier ist unser Zucker
zwei Knoblauchzehen ich glaube ich habe
vorhin versehentlich Ingwer gerieben
gesagt was Knoblauch außerdem ein
bisschen was von unserer
Frühlingszwiebel die schon fein
geschnitten habe den Rest brauchen wir
noch zum garniert so das ganze verkneten
wir
wenn das ganze schön verknetet ist
nehmen wir uns so kleine Ecken davon
zweite Hand nehmen wir dazu und Formen
einfach wirklich so leineboards da raus
wieso markbällchen genau
wenn Sie fertig sind schön klein und so
geben wir sie jetzt Stück für Stück rein
in unserer conji wo sie dann quasi
langsam durchgaren und noch schön hart
sind echt gespannt wie das Ganze
schmecken wird ich habe hohe Erwartungen
jetzt anders Frühstück entwickelt laut
Rezept 3 Minuten dann ist ein bisschen
krass dass sie nur 3 Minuten da drin
Köchen sein damit die auch wirklich
durch sind
[Musik]
das sieht gut aus und es sieht vor allem
so aus als würde es einen wirklich satt
machen und das brauche ich gerade es
riecht frisch es riecht nach dem Sesamöl
was ich gerade am Ende noch mal
drübergegeben habe und Ingwer
Frühlingszwiebeln es ist einfach es ist
lecker glaube ich überzeuge mich jetzt
mal davon nehme mir einen Löffel mit dem
Vergleich mit Porridge eigentlich
perfekt also konjugie ist halt von der
Konstanze genauso und wir probieren
ist krass man sieht ja auch schon so wie
Porridge auch ist das so ein bisschen so
schleimig möchte ich sagen was halt kein
schönes Wort ist zum Essen zu
beschreiben die Konsistenz ist trotzdem
sehr sehr gut also es ist so eine
richtig angenehme schöne Konsistenz
total cremig fast so ein bisschen wie
man vielleicht so ein vollkommen
übertriebenes Risotto von der Cremigkeit
ja der Geschmack ist super ich habe
gedacht wo ist das Salz aber das Salz
ist halt die Sojasoße probiere ich mal
so ein dazu
das ist wirklich ein krasses essen also
vor allen Dingen auch ein ganz
besonderes Frühstück oder nicht ja also
für Frühstück ganz was anderes ganz was
anderes das hat er wirklich nichts mit
unserer frühstückskultur zu tun mit
Süßigkeiten oder belegten Brötchen oder
irgendwas sondern es ist eigentlich
etwas was man in Deutschland nicht als
Frühstück klassifizieren würde aber es
ist in der Hinsicht ein gutes Frühstück
das einem Kraft für den Tag gibt dass es
sehr technisch mal was leckeres im Bauch
bring morgens schon sowas warmes im
Bauch zu haben finde ich es immer was
sehr sehr schön passt auch irgendwie
gerade in die Jahreszeit so was Warmes
irgendwie sowieso ein herzhafter
Milchreis so ein bisschen
vielleicht auch eine Sache die nicht
jedermann kennt aber das Mittagessen
dürfte jeder von euch kennen aber ob es
auch so einfach ist sehen wir jetzt Zeit
fürs Mittagessen und was soll ich sagen
wir brauchen nicht allzu viel alles was
wir brauchen ist diese Partei Mischung
das alles drin die ist aus Thailand
damit mischt man einfach alles zusammen
und hat dann das perfekte Partei
entweder man macht es so oder man
braucht Ei das hier wir haben
Hähnchenbrust Maisstärke Knoblauch Eier
Schalotten Erdnüsse getrocknete Shrimps
Schnittlauch Sojasprossen Palm Zucker
Pups einmal hinten Püree Limetten dunkle
Sojasoße Fischsoße und süße Soße wir
machen es natürlich auf die richtige Art
und Weise wobei ich mir sicher bin weil
wenn das aus Thailand kommt ist es
bestimmt auch nicht verkehrt vielleicht
eine andere Mal kein Video drehen auf
entspannt fangen wir an als allererstes
machen wir unsere Soße dafür brauchen
wir eine Schüssel wir brauchen einen
dieser Palmen Zucker kaputt wir brauchen
Fischsoße schwarze Sojasauce und
tamarinden aller erstes einmal reibe ich
diesen Palmen zu kaputt ich finde das
wirklich verrückt weil das kennt man so
einfach nicht das sieht aus wie Parmesan
so ein bisschen wenn man das so
durchreißt irgendwie kleiner Reibe durch
die wir das ziehen aber es gibt Palm
Zucker auch in röselform aber ich glaube
das hier ist so der real deal wenn man
das in diesen Festen Pucks hat löst sich
natürlich auch perfekt gleich in unserer
Soße auf und es riecht ganz so süß
irgendwie und es ist wirklich ein
bisschen Arbeit das so zu reiben aber
ich bin mir sicher die Arbeit lohnt sich
ich mache das hier erstmal so sieht das
ganze dann aus schön fluffig aber
trotzdem so zu Krieg es schmilzt so ein
Mund fast so ein bisschen wie
Puderzucker sehr lecker probieren das
zerfällt so auf der Zunge oha oha dann
nehmen wir unser Püree eben davon so 100
ml rein und ich füge noch ein bisschen
Wasser hinzu weil ich möchte gerne ein
bisschen flüssiger haben dann können wir
das ganze schon mal ein wenig umrühren
sich der Zucker darin auch auflöst zwei
Esslöffel Fischsoße dieselbe Fischsoße
aus dem Frühstück auch oder Fischsoße
ist Fischsoße sage ich immer ein
Esslöffel von der schwarzen Sojasauce
boah die ist ja so geleeartig richtig
schön dickflüssig geil wie viel es
riecht super Alter
Zucker drin aber es riecht eher nach
Zucker aber so kennt man ja auch diese
Partei so dass sie so richtig so süß
sauer ist hammerinde an sich ist ja auch
süß sauer und so verbinden wir das ganze
verstehst du dass das hier der pure
Geschmack ist probiert es einfach mal
das ist so intense aber das ist schon
jetzt ist das schon so ein Partei
Geschmack aber wir haben noch einiges an
Arbeit vor uns als Proteinquelle haben
wir Hähnchen das habe ich klein
geschnitten das ist Hähnchenbrust die
geben wir in eine Schüssel gemeinsam mit
einem Teelöffel Maisstärke also einfach
Speisestärke dazu kommt ein ordentlicher
Schluck sweet soy source die ist noch
dickflüssiger Hörner weißer Pfeffer und
Salz zack dann massieren wir unsere
Marinade die wir gerade gemacht haben in
unser chicken ein und das ist dann
während der nächsten
vorbereitungsschritten einfach ein wenig
ruhen den Geschmack aufnehmen denn ich
sage euch so viel Geschmack haben wir
auf jeden Fall genug heute nächstes
Werkzeug das wir brauchen ein food
processer also einfach man kann das
alles auch mit Hand machen aber das hier
macht es deutlich entspannter im
bereiten einmal unsere getrockneten
shrimpsform auch so etwas so getrocknete
schwimmt ja trocknet
ja Supermarkt wichtig sehr sehr wichtig
und ab geht's
das ist glaube ich eine der kernzutaten
um einen wirklich authentischen
Geschmack zu bekommen mit vielleicht der
tamarindenpaste weil sowas hier das sind
halt so viele Shrimps gibt auch so viel
Geschmack kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen am Ende kommt eh alles
zusammen deshalb gebe ich auch meine
Erdnüsse die ich ein bisschen fein
hacken will einfach nur zum Garnieren
später in den food processer macht für
mich auch immer ganz viel bei so einem
Partei noch so diese leckeren Erdnüsse
die so ein Crunch geben und so super
alles gehexelt was gehäkelt werden muss
und wer aufmerksam ist halt im
Hintergrund gesehen dass wir da ein paar
Nudeln schon vorbereitet haben Partei
Reisnudeln gibt's in verschiedener Dicke
wir haben ein bisschen dünnere genommen
die Nudeln habe ich einfach mit Kochen
im Wasser übergossen bisschen ziehen
lassen so dass sie jetzt noch ein
bisschen Biss haben zack so brauchen sie
jetzt ist es Zeit für ein Bekenntnis ich
habe keinen richtigen Rock ich habe eine
Bock Pfanne ich hoffe ich kriege das
damit halbwegs gut hin weil ich habe mir
wirklich Mühe gegeben mit allem aber ich
weiß wo Bock muss eigentlich sein jetzt
geben wir einen hitzebeständiges Öl
Erdnussöl in die Pfanne und er anders
einmal so richtig schön durch also wir
müssen jetzt mutig sein wenn unser Wok
heiß ist geben wir unser Hähnchen hinein
und jetzt braten wir das Ganze ein wenig
an
ja komm das muss reichen gehen wir an
die Seite unsere Pfanne unser Wok wird
weitergebraucht mit jeder Menge Öl dass
wir erstmal wieder schön heiß werden
lassen in der Zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal drei Eier verkühlen für uns
die geben jetzt rein
einmal schön durch wenn das ganze ein
bisschen gekocht ist geben wir zwei fein
geschnittene Schalotten dazu und wenn
die verlocken auch so ein bisschen Hitze
bekommen haben und vor sich hin gekocht
sind geben wir unsere Nudeln dazu auf
einen Schlag Zack
und mit den Nudeln auch unsere Soße
oh yeah let's go mach da vorne ein
bisschen Platz schüttet das Ei hinein
zack lass mir jetzt ein wenig ankochen
so dann ziehen wir das ganze einfach zu
unserem Partei hinein habe hier noch ein
wenig frischen Knoblauch den ich entlang
des Weges vergessen habe Schnittlauch
bzw eigentlich Knoblauch Schnittlauch
chinesischen Knoblauch Schnittlauch
haben wir nicht bekommen bzw haben wir
bekommen aber leider vergammelt das
machen wir das ganz einfach so ein paar
von unseren Mungobohnen und unser
chicken Mama mir ich weiß nicht ob die
Nudeln zu durch sind aber ich glaube es
wird vor allem einfach nur gut schmecken
[Musik]
hier ist es also Partei das
thailändische Nationalgericht ganz
traditionell serviert auf einem
Bananenblatt geben noch ein bisschen
Limette oben drüber ja ich nehme hier
ein paar von unseren Reisnudeln einmal
damit rein dampft noch direkt aus der
Wokpfanne probiert
ja das hättet jeden einzelnen Punkt von
Partei den ich schon mal in so einem
Imbiss gegessen habe aber es ist so als
hättest du den geschmacksregler weiter
aufgedreht so als würde es einfach noch
nach noch mehr schmecken echt oh diese
tamarinden Soße weißt du wie man auf
Deutsch aber Tini ist das perfekt Wort
oder so am Gaumen so so weißt du diese
Limette noch das kitzelt wirklich so an
deiner Schädeldecke wenn du das ist und
das ist kein Spaß also da da ist so viel
Geschmack und so viel unbekannter
Geschmack auch drin
ich kann jetzt auch nicht mehr
weiterreden du musst auch eine Gabe
essen
so ich will dass du das gerade genießt
und ist ich will jetzt auch selbst egal
was ist das für ein Mundgefühl auch okay
lass uns das aufessen auf zum Abendessen
auf zur Abendessen
ein Glück dass ich nicht noch mal in die
Küche muss ich sage euch so viel darauf
hätte ich jetzt gar keine Lust umso mehr
freue ich mich dass wir vor einem
authentischen Teil street food Laden
sind hier gibt es scheinbar alles was
das thailändische Herz kulinarische
thailändische Herz begehrt wir gucken
mal was das so ist weil ich weiß gar
nicht genau was bestellen werde ich habe
Lust auf so einem typisches Abendessen
wir gehen einfach mal rein und wir
bestellen ist
[Musik]
kommen wir zum Abend essen ich habe hier
ein grünes Teig Curry mit Tofu und hier
drüben ein Song tam Thai also ein
thailändischen Papaya Salat bin gespannt
wo ihr die Papaya ist ich glaube die ist
da die Farben mit drin das sind die
Fasern die Papaya ich hatte irgendwie
mit was anderem gerechnet das auf jeden
Fall sehr typisch sein und auch erstmal
die typisch heute mit Stäbchen am Essen
deshalb muss ich bestimmt doppelt so gut
schmecken probieren
[Musik]
weniger süß dafür so eine starke Säure
war unfassbar erfrischend dieser Salat
darauf habe ich den ganzen Tag Lust
seitdem wir heute morgen einkaufen waren
dann ist nämlich die Dame im Supermarkt
gesagt dass wir auch das Partei mit
frittiertem Tofu machen können das habe
ich ihn endlich
das grüne Curry hat auch Bums das ist
schön scharf ja ich weiß nicht ob es ist
weil ich gesagt habe dass wir
authentisch thailändisch
Schärfe okay dann habe ich Angst wenn du
das schon sagst es ist lecker ist eine
schöne geschmacksschärfe aber es ist auf
jeden Fall authentisch ich glaub daran
merkt man das authentisch ist und nicht
an deutschen Gaumen angefasst ich habe
mir ein Partei bestellt und du
vergleichen uns zu vergleichen aber
Vergleich du bezahlst ersten darauf bin
ich auch sehr gespannt das ist ja nicht
allzu lange her man sieht die Nudeln
sind auf jeden Fall die breiterin die
Zutaten sind auch im Prinzip dieselben
ne also es ist eigentlich genau
[Musik]
deutlich süßer als unseres okay Plus ist
hat weniger von diesem tamarinden
Geschmack ich weiß noch bis vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr an den deutschen Markt
angepasst ist einfach nicht falsch
verstehen du meinst damit ja auch nicht
dass deins richtiger schmeckt ne das
sind einfach nur die Unterschiede die du
jetzt schmeckst aber unfassbar lecker
das was wir gemacht
als ich sonst was das wäre wirklich
schon maximal intensiv und das schmeckt
sehr süß sehr lecker sehr klassisch wie
man sie in Deutschland kann leider ich
sag's euch das war wirklich nicht von
schlechten Eltern ich habe alles außer
Hunger jetzt nach diesem Tag es war
unfassbar gut thailändische Küche hat
mich auf jeden Fall voll und ganz
überzeugt ich weiß gar nicht was mein
Favorit war wobei doch ich weiß es schon
Partei das war krass echt auch mal
thailändisch schreib mir in die
Kommentare welche Land jetzt als
nächstes kulinarische reisen sollen und
vergessen nicht auf dieses für oder
vergisst du nicht auf dieses für dich
so vergessen nicht auf das auf dieses
für dich vorgeschlagene Video zu klicken
oder den Kanal zu abonnieren bisschen
kom das Auto aber danke fürs zuschauen
bis zum nächsten Mal Ciao komm wir gehen
zum Auto das ist in die Richtung
[Musik]